we tested 50 chocolate chip cookie
recipes and this is the best one
perfect the number one secret to a
perfect chocolate chip cookie is to
brown your butter it adds that nutty
Rich depth of flavor that you would find
in your local bakery you lose some of
the water during the Browning process so
we recommend adding a few tablespoons
back in for a chewy soft texture we
recommend using a mixture of bread and
all-purpose flour we also like adding in
a teaspoon of espresso powder to enhance
the chocolate flavor and the best cookie
dough consistency uses one egg yolk
mixed with one regular egg the extra fat
from the yolk gives baked goods that
extra rich flavor after combining the
dry ingredients with the wet mixture our
final tip is to include bigger pieces of
chopped chocolate in addition to smaller
chips to create the perfect Wells of
gooey goodness you can find the full
recipe for the perfect chocolate chip
cookie on tasty.com